UNDER 40% SHOOTING.
>> Mike: MARK, IT WAS THE THIRD
QUARTER THAT TURNED IT AROUND IN
GAME THREE.
THIRD QUARTER TURNED IT AROUND
HERE FOR PHOENIX.
>> Mark: BIG WIN.
NOT JUST INDIVIDUALLY, BUT
COLLECTIVELY.
SHOULD BE PROUD OF THE WIN THAT
CAME UP.
>> Mike: LET'S GO RACHEL.
>> Rachel: CHRIS,
CONGRATULATIONS.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO GET HOME
COURT IN THIS SERIES AND GRAB
THIS WIN?
>> A LOT.
SHOWED A LOT OF FIGHT.
SHOWED A LOT OF FIGHT, MAN.
GUYS ON BOTH SIDES.
BANGED UP.
THAT'S THE PLAYOFFS.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S GOING TO LOOK
LIKE.
BUT WE SHOWED A LOT OF FIGHT AND
GOT THIS WIN.
>> Rachel: MONTY THINKS YOUR
REINING OF MOTION WAS THE BEST
SINCE THE INJURY.
HOW DO YOU FEEL?
WHAT DID YOU HAVE TO DO THE LAST
COUPLE DAYS TO GET ON THE COURT?
>> MAN, IT'S BEEN OWE LOT GOING
ON.
MET WITH COACH BEFORE THE GAME.
HE TOLD ME HE WAS GOING SIT ME
TONIGHT.
I TOLD HIM, HELL NO.
JUST GIVE ME A COUPLE MINUTES.
SEE WHAT I CAN DO.
GOD IS GOOD.
I COME FROM A PRAYING FAMILY.
MY MAMA AND DADDY ALL DAY LONG
PRAY FOR ME.
THIS IS JUST A GAME.
PEOPLE GOT A LOT OF TOUGHER
THINGS GOING ON.
BUT I LOVE THE PLAY THIS GAME,
SO JUST SO GET OUT THERE AND BE
ABLE TO APPLY THIS GAME -- IT'S
2-2.
STILL GOT A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
>>